All right.
We have breaking news right now.
Rupert Murdoch has now announced
he is stepping down
as the chairman of Fox Corporation
and Fox News.
Let me bring in
CNN senior media reporter Oliver Darcy
for more on this.
It's been a long awaited question of what
his plans were for the future,
what his succession plan was.
This is a big news today.
This is huge news.
Rupert Murdoch
saying
telling employees that he's stepping down
as chairman of Fox Corp.
and also News Corp
which is his publishing arm.
He wrote to employees
saying he's in good health,
but now is the time to step down.
I want to read to you
part of the note
that just went out to employees
moments ago.
It says here on my phone,
the time is right for me
to take on different roles,
knowing that we have truly talented teams
and a passionate principle leader.
And Lachlan, his son,
who will become
the chairman of both companies.
And of course, Rupert Murdoch
is one of the most powerful media moguls
in the world.
Fox News,
everyone familiar with it is the arguably
the strongest
organ in the right wing media ecosystem.
It propped up Donald Trump
for many years.
I think most people would suggest
that Donald Trump
was strongly protected,
obviously, by Fox News. And this is
Rupert Murdoch,
you know, biggest media company.
And so he he controls all this.
So him
stepping down
will obviously have
not only impact in the media world,
but also in the political world.
I'm just looking at this at this at this
memo, a letter that you for it
kindly forwarded to me.
And just looking at even
just the second graph of this, neither
excessive pride
nor false humility
or admirable qualities,
but I'm truly proud of what we have
achieved collectively
through the decades.
And I owe much of my colleagues
whose contributions to our success
have sometimes been unseen
outside the company
but are deeply appreciated by me.
I mean, this is this is real.
I mean, this is like the swansong.
This is his farewell to the company.
And interestingly, talk to me about land.
And what this now means is
he now takes on officially
a very huge role.
Yeah. This is real life succession.
So Lachlan Murdoch
has been the chief executive
of Fox of these companies.
But now he's going to take on this role
as as chairman
and really lead it officially.
He's now he's
now leading the companies
without his father at his side.
I think most people,
you know,
Lachlan has been chief executive,
but most people would still say
that Rupert was really the one
making the major calls behind the scenes
when it comes to things.
But now Lachlan is in the driver's seat
and he has come out on top.
You know,
there was a lot of questions
over the years
who would take over these companies
initially. Absolutely.
I mean, Murdoch yes, son would take over.
Then Lachlan came in
and became chief executive
and now Lachlan is
the one who is the heir apparent
or apparent the heir, the
the now the man in that
will be in charge.
What does this say
and what do you think
this will portend for this
massive media company for the direction
that is Fox News for?
I mean, he is not just any media mogul.
He had a strong hand in the direction
things took
and the people
that were put in charge,
like the era of Roger Ailes. Right.
I think if someone like James Murdoch,
the son who is
tends to be more liberal on things
to come into power,
I think that would mean
major changes
are coming to the companies.
But with Lachlan Murdoch,
I think he's much more aligned
probably with his father's vision.
He said to be very conservative
on a lot of things.
And so I'm not sure how much of a change
editorial you'll see, but
certainly there's
going to be some change.
You know, Lachlan is not his father.
And so what that looks like,
I don't know
I can tell you right now,
but I would imagine that someone
new coming in, taking the throne,
that is going to lead to some change.
It's so interesting
because even in this even in this
letter he takes a shot at
the elites, which is
always a
fascinating kind of juxtaposition because
he's the definition of a media elite.
You could very clearly say.
But he also ends this
with talking about in my new role.
Is there any word of what new role
he's talking about?
Like this is not him going into
but is this effectively
he is going into retirement
or he's taking on a different project
from here on out?
I don't think anyone's ever going to say
that Rupert Murdoch
is going into retirement.
I don't think that's something
that is capable of those words
he's not capable of uttering.
But I do think this is as close
as we're
probably going to get to him
announcing that he is stepping down.
I mean, he is announcing stepping down
from from these roles. I mean, he's 92.
So while people say he is in
great health, he has
some had had some health
scares over the years.
And I imagine that
even if you are an incredibly
healthy natural
you know, running these companies is a
is a huge task.
And so you need someone
who's able to devote
the full attention
that it takes
to run these massive media companies.
And he's he's saying that he's
going to hand it off to Lachlan.
Well and you've done so much
reporting over the years of just kind of
I keep wanting to call it the
success of this succession,
but it really is
that it's not just that amazing series
of kind of how he had for years,
tried to groom his sons
and like put them in positions.
I remember
just stories about
it was either Lachlan
or James that he would put in
is like an internship
they put him in internships
in the various companies
and the headlines
that would come out from it
when one of them falls
was seen as falling asleep
on the job or something.
And just kind of what this is,
it is a family family affair
for for the Murdochs
and what it is also done to this family.
Yeah.
And the empire used to be a lot
bigger, right?
I mean, Rupert sold
a lot of the empire to Disney,
you know, the movie studio.
And so now the empire that Lachlan
will be taking
hold of, it's still very powerful.
It still has Fox News,
you know, The Wall Street Journal,
some very powerful entities in it.
But it's not the big
entertainment company that this once was.
It is now mostly a news company.
And in a sports company,
they do Fox Sports, obviously,
but it's not the big media giant. It was.
And so
while he is taking over,
I think that it's not necessarily
the throne.
The empire isn't as big as it once was.
Right.
There's so much.
Is it
going to be a lot of reaction
coming in and a lot of wonder,
you know, what
now happens
if there are any questions left
now that we know that Lachlan
is in charge?
Stick around.
I know you've got more reporting to come.
So thank you so much.
For running up here, though, all Oliver,
on this breaking news.